c'est la surprise et les mois du côté de
ceux qui connaissent ivan safronov
d'autant que d'après son employeur
l'agencé spatiale russe roskosmos son
arrestation n'est pas lié à son emploi
actuel est d'après le porte-parole du
kremlin
elle n'est pas liée non plus à ses
précédentes enquêtes du temps où il
était encore journaliste
quoi qu'il en soit dimitri peskov a fait
savoir qu'il fallait mettre de côté les
émotions et laisser travailler la
justice
nous avons lu de nombreux articles
publiés à ce sujet mais tous ces
articles journalistiques sont
principalement basées sur des émotions
il est évident qu'ils ne contiennent pas
et ne peuvent pas contenir des
informations réelles sur les résultats
du travail du service de contre
espionnage
c'est très simple cette affaire doit
être examiné dans le tribunal
il y à une accusation il y a les
résultats du travail des services suez
fini la décision sera prise par le
tribunal de 2010 à 2019 silvan safronov
était journaliste au sein de la
rédaction du quotidien économique russe
kommersant où il était spécialisé dans
les domaines de la coopération militaire
ou encore dans le spatial et le fesf et
le soupçonne donc d'avoir transmis
d'avoir livré des informations aux
services secrets tchèque entre 2012 et
2017 des informations en lien avec des
livraisons d'armes russes au moyen
orient et dans plusieurs pays d'afrique
en conséquence yvonne safronov a été
placé en détention provisoire pour une
durée de deux mois et risque jusqu'à 20
ans de prison
son avocat pour sa part regrette ces
accusations à l'encontre de son client
et entend bien faire appel de cette
décision de justice en tant que partie
de la défense nous considérons la
décision prise aujourd'hui par le
tribunal de district de l'est photo rv
au comme illégale et infondée
il est évident et feront appel dans les
délais fixés par la loi
mais pour le moment l'enquète
préliminaire est en cours
l'enquète durera très probablement aussi
longtemps qu'habituellement
quand il s'agit de telles affaires donc
personne ne s'est précipité ensuite
étant donné qu'il s'agit d'informations
constitue un secret d'état
je le répète encore une fois c'est ce
qu'affirme enquête alors on s'attend à
ce que le procès se déroulent également
à huis clos
parmi ses ex collègues on s'étonne aussi
de ces accusations il a reçu de nombreux
soutiens via les réseaux sociaux
notamment mais aussi il y à un
rassemblement qui s'est déroulé dans la
journée de mardi en plein centre de
moscou et à l'issue duquel plusieurs
arrestations ont eu lieu
place maintenant à l'instruction de
cette affaire dont les médias n'auront
hélas pas grand accès en raison du
caractère sensible classé secret d'état
de cette affaire